why
so due to the large number of civil war
tie-ins between the main issues of the
civil war story arc we're going to begin
the process of splitting these videos up
and so what we're going to do is in this
portion of the discussion we're going to
focus on the events leading up to Civil
War frontline issue number two and then
we'll follow that pattern accordingly
well we'll talk about the next set of
tie-ins after Civil War frontline issue
number two until we've completed all the
tie ins between civil war issues number
two and number three
so as we continue our discussions
regarding the tie-ins between civil war
issue number two and issue number three
we actually have to jump back to before
Civil War issue number two and talk
about Civil War frontline issue number
one
now the Civil War frontline comics are
very very important and the reason why
is because these 11 limited issue comics
really are going to give us the down
gritty dirty part of what's going on
with civil war where the main Civil War
storyline itself will focus on the idea
of superheroes battling each other and
really will kind of lead to this
grandiose conflict and these solo
tie-ins as far as Wolverine and she-hulk
and other individuals go focus on those
people the frontline comics give us
perspective on the guys that just really
wouldn't get a lot of notoriety the
down-home backyard street-level kind of
heroes the ones that aren't big they're
aren't they aren't well-known they're
not part of major teams and really gives
us an idea of just how deep this rift
goes between the superheroes and their
stance over the superhuman Registration
Act
so Civil War frontline issue number one
introduces us to two characters the
first person is Sally Floyd and the
second person is Ben Urich now these two
individuals as we progress through the
frontline series will really kind of
begin to represent two camps the first
is pro registration and the second is
anti registration Ben Urich for the most
part is per registration and we actually
see that in his early kind of speech as
he's conversing with Sally Floyd
although it's not until later on that he
will really kind of be pull
to end to being part of the per
registration movement by Ironman Sally
Floyd is really kind of interviewing
spider-man as we progress through the
story and what we see is spider-man
really kind of revealing his most his
deepest concern with regards to the
superhuman Registration Act and the way
that he does it he is really also kind
of voicing the concerns of most
everybody else who was against
registration now as we know with civil
war issue number two Spider Man reveals
himself simply because he really kind of
feels honor bound to ally himself with
Iron Man but as he is conversing with
Sally Floyd he tells her that these
people who are superheroes are not just
kind of running around and partying and
doing whatever and just kind of having a
good time that they have just as much to
lose as anybody else that their mothers
and fathers and sons and daughters and
brothers and sisters and that
supervillains and other individuals
normal humans who would seek to do them
harm will have a greater way to do that
will have an easier way to target them
if they know what their real identities
are and this particularly hits home for
spider-man because throughout the
publication history of the Spider Man
comics Peter Parker was really kind of
always able to maintain this invisible
wall between individuals that would seek
to do them harm and people that know his
actual identity it was a way for him to
keep people like Mary Jane Watson and
Aunt May safe especially after the death
of when Stacy story arc where she was
killed by the Green Goblin Norman Osborn
and so for him when he's talking with
Sally Floyd he says his biggest concern
is that people who didn't previously
know his real identity will now know
what it is and they'll be able to target
those that he loves a lot easier and
really kind of target them in a way to
where their goal is to directly either
I guess maybe cut spider-man out of the
scene entirely or to rent him virtually
incapable to the point that he doesn't
want to be spider-man anymore because of
the emotional emotional turmoil now from
this point we cut to the reveal of Tony
Stark letting people know that he is
Iron Man now this isn't necessarily a
huge scene in the sense that he is
revealing himself to be Iron Man this
has been done before but it's really
kind of a big scene because one of the
biggest parts of Tony Stark's character
and Marvel Comics is that he's an
alcoholic and it's not something that he
makes known to everybody it's really
only something that
the reader and a handful of other
individuals no but this is really kind
of him coming out and really kind of
baring it all and kind of setting this
this example that if he is going to side
as a superhero with the idea that
superheroes should register himself a
register themselves and he is going to
kind of lead this forefront then he
should be the first one to take the
first step which he does in addition the
fact that he is now coming out and
telling people that he is an alcoholic
means that they were going to be
personal ramifications in his own
personal life that are going to be a
result of this but for him it's more of
doing what he perceives to be the right
thing than doing what may be
uncomfortable or maybe something that he
thinks will be personally painful for
him now after this we actually get a
reveal that's pretty big and this is
very important as we progress through
the Civil War story what we learn is
that speedball one of the members of the
New Warriors who added had encountered
nitro and it really kind of forced nitro
into the situation where he's self
destructed is actually alive and he is
taken to a hospital and as he comes to
we learned that he's under arrest the
individual that is presiding over him is
part of the shield anti superhuman
Registration terrorist movement meaning
that he is part of shield and the NSA
and is there to ensure that individuals
who do not register are placed under
arrest and he tells speedball four
things the first thing he tells him is
that he is the only survivor of the
incident in Stamford Connecticut the
second thing he tells him is that the
casualties ranged anywhere between six
hundred and a thousand and at least 60
of the people who were killed were
children the third thing that he tells
him is that because of the fact that he
had absorbed the brunt of impact from
nitros explosion and that the brunt of
the impact with regards to his kinetic
energy absorbing powers had kind of
conflicted with the synapses in his
brain he is now virtually powerless he
is unable to use his abilities to do
anything at all because his abilities
abilities do not exist the fourth thing
that he tells him is that he's under
arrest
and this really kind of brings an end to
the civil war front line issue number
one comic
so Thunderbolts issue number 103 brings
Baron hell museam oh and the
Thunderbolts into the fold
regarding the Civil War event now the
way that the Thunderbolts were
originally founded is really kind of
interesting the Thunderbolts were formed
as a new version of the Masters of evil
under Baron hell museam oh the son of
Baron Heinrich Zemo who was Captain
America's enemy during world war ii and
the whole basis of this new formation of
the masters of evil was to infiltrate
the Avengers masquerading as a group
called the Thunderbolts and destroy the
Avengers from within however the longer
that these villains played the role of
superheroes the more they began to enjoy
the role of superheroes and so after a
conflict that really kind of resulted in
Baron hell muse emo almost sacrificing
his life for Captain America we really
kind of see them becoming a superhero
group looking for redemption now as we
the story progresses the story kind of
unfolds regarding a Thunderbolts issue
number 103 we see that the Thunderbolts
are recruited by Tony Stark ant-man Reed
Richards and Peter Garrick in order to
play the role of tracking down
supervillains who refused to register
and recruiting them to the cause of the
pro registration movement now this is
when we really kind of see Tony start
getting into less than savory methods of
promoting the superhuman Registration
movement and this is when we really kind
of see him ally himself with people who
are dubious at best because we don't
really know what the intentions are as
far as Baron helm use emo goes and this
this part of the comic we don't really
know what it is that he wants to do we
don't know if he is truly just
masquerading as a good guy and is it
hard a bad guy or if he really is
looking for redemption and this kind of
dubious nature of him as a person is of
course mentioned and discussed with Reed
Richards and ant-man and Tony start
directly with bear and helm use emo
because of the shady history that both
of those groups have in the past they're
not really sure whether they can trust
them or not but at this point it's
really the best option that they have
now as the story progresses we see that
the first assignment that bear in hell
museum Oh gets is to track down various
supervillains he's successful in doing
that
but as the comet comes to a close we
actually learn what his intentions are
and that while the Thunderbolts issue
number 103 comic took place or begins to
take place two weeks after the events of
Stamford Connecticut three weeks or a
week before the events of Stamford
Connecticut the Thunderbolts had already
begun rounding up various superheroes
and supervillains and the Marvel
community and we're really kind of
indoctrinating them to their own cause
so that Barron helm uz Bo could build up
an army for his own purposes so amazing
spider-man issue number 533 is a very
interesting comic because this comic
book follows the aftermath of Peter
Parker revealing his identity publicly
and as we'll see the fallout of this
really kind of compounds on itself time
and time again and things really kind of
go from bad to worse regarding the life
of Peter Parker the first reaction that
Peter Parker has to revealing his public
identity is that he's physically sick he
really actually starts vomiting in one
of the restrooms and then he confronts
Tony Stark and tells Tony Stark that
should anything happen to him that he is
to take care of the Tony Stark is to
take care of Mary Jane Watson and Aunt
May but if anything happens to Mary Jane
Watson and Aunt May that Peter Parker
spider-man will directly come after Tony
Stark from there we see that when Peter
Parker arrives home that his home is
totally flooded with the press everybody
really wants to ask him questions and
we're really kind of given questions of
our own as the reader you know we see
that this kind of maybe compilation so
to speak on the pages begins to unfold
where we see individuals like Eddie
Brock come to the realization that he
the Peter Parker is spider-man when he
reveals his identity we see that Rhino
and various other individuals see that
he reveals his identity as Peter Parker
in addition were also left to ask the
question what's going to happen
regarding both super heroes and super
villains the super villains of
spider-man now know his personal
identity they know who he is and they
know exactly how to attack him in a way
that will make him the most vulnerable
and could possibly render him totally
out of the scene as far as being
spider-man but we also kind of has to
ask the question that if spider-man is
one of the most prominent superheroes in
the world
and has kept his personal identity so
close to himself so well so well guarded
what are these superheroes are going to
do are they going to look at him as kind
of the standard are they going to follow
his lead or are they going to entrench
themselves further underground after
seeing the aftermath of Peter Parker
coming out publicly in addition once
he's at home and he's with Aunt May and
Mary Jane we see that Tony Stark is
speaking publicly and addressing the
issue of what they're going to do to
round up various super-powered beings
because shield can't do it by themselves
any states that a new team is being
formed to round up those super-powered
individuals who refuse to register
themselves and that Peter Parker
spider-man is going to be one of them
now this really takes Peter Parker by
surprise because he did not sign up for
this
he wasn't even made aware that this is
something that Tony Stark intended to do
so he and Mary Jane leave to confront
Tony Stark but they take the back alley
because the front of the apartment is
covered with the press as they leave
into the back alley they realized the
back alley is covered with press and a
fan of Captain America makes an attempt
on Peter Parker and Mary Jane's life
Peter Parker is successful in stopping
it and this individual is apprehended
and Peter Parker goes to meet Tony Stark
dressed in his spider-man outfit he
confronts Tony Stark and says that he
did not sign up for this this is not
something that he agreed with and he
thoroughly disliked Iron Man signing him
up for something that he didn't know
about
he tells Tony Stark that should anything
like this ever happen again that he has
to be informed so that he can make sure
that preparations are made for his loved
ones in case another attempt is made on
their life from there the comic book
comes to an end as we see this team that
Tony Stark is formed which consists of
some of the most prominent superheroes
in the Marvel Universe with the
exception of Captain America and his
side of things and this is really kind
of important here because this is where
we see the line officially being drawn
this is really where Marvel gives it to
us that there are now two main cancer
superheroes if ever there were anything
to tell us who's on what side this is it
you have virtually all these individuals
who are now on Tony Stark's side now the
numbers will bolster and they will grow
as we progress throughout the civil war
storyline but we are also kind of left
to see that the most prominent members
the Fantastic Four the Thunderbolt
ant-man Hank Pym the wasp that all these
individuals are now on the side of Tony
Stark and then we will ultimately switch
to the position of Captain America and
we will see the entire side of things
from Captain America's perspective so
Civil War frontline issue number two
follow some major events as they unfold
in the Civil War storyline and we
actually see some great storytelling in
this college I would go as far as to say
that this is probably some of the best
storytelling in the entire Civil War
event the comic opens up with Ben Urich
revealing that he knew who Peter Parker
was that he knew Peter Parker was
spider-man they had been longtime
friends and of course we had previously
seen this in the Marvel Comics in
spider-man's publication history and we
learned that Ben Urich is going to be
the one writing the expose on behalf of
the Daily Bugle about Peter Parker and
spider-man
but he wants to do it in a way to where
he can make Peter Parker a grey guy but
not betray the friendship at the two of
them have from there we switched to
Sally Floyd and Sally Floyd is
interviewing Firestar and this I think
is one of the coolest aspects to the
comics because this again touches on the
smaller characters the smaller
superheroes that don't have major roles
that don't have major publication
histories or anything like that and
really kind of gives us this idea of how
the civil superhuman Registration
affects the small-time superheroes and
what we see is that Firestar is really
not going to register but she's not
going to be a superhero either she has a
day job she has you know
responsibilities and these really aren't
things that she can sacrifice she's
putting herself through college and so
on and so forth if it became public that
she was a superhero that her public
identity was revealed she could lose her
job and she could lose the ability to
take care of herself and this I think is
one of the best parts of the Civil War
story because I think that a lot of the
idea that people have when it comes to
superheroes is that superheroes go out
and fight crime
and their needs is kind of taken care of
by some kind of mystical means they
somehow managed to get food
maybe somebody gives them food people
just give them money or something like
that but with this story we see that
they have jobs that they have lives
outside of being superheroes and that
those lives allow them to continue their
existence they allow them to continue to
live allow them to further their careers
because some some of these people don't
want to be superheroes for the long term
they want actual day jobs they want a
peaceful life and they don't want to
fight crime forever and so what we see
is that Firestar actually abandons her
role as a superhero and kind of returns
to her normal life from there we jump to
Jay jonah Jameson and Jay jonah Jameson
really kind of feels betrayed by Peter
Parker he employed Peter Parker Peter
Parker was a great employee for him and
the job of Peter Parker was to provide
him with evidence that would incriminate
spider-man but because Peter Parker was
spider-man we had seen over the course
of Peter Parker in spider-man's
publication history that he had really
kind of give him given him small bit
stuff that wouldn't really incriminate
Peter Parker or spider-man or wouldn't
even really lead to the identity of
spider-man as Peter Parker being
revealed Jay jonah Jameson feels
betrayed by this he feels like all this
time he had been defrauded by Peter
Parker that Peter Parker had essentially
been tricking him and making a fool out
of him we learned that he doesn't
actually want to do an expose on
spider-man anymore he wants to abandon
the entire idea of spider-man and focus
on superheroes that are pro registration
and really kind of build them up but we
learned that this really isn't going to
work out that the goal the job of The
Daily Bugle is to sell itself
and so if they go away if they walk away
from the hot topic at the moment which
is spider-man
they will lose money to other news
outlets from there we jump to prodigy
and prodigy is a superhero who had been
around for a while but was really kind
of a smaller guy wasn't a great big huge
superhero on a level of Tony Stark or
Captain America or anybody like that and
this part of the comic takes place one
minute before the midnight deadline for
superhuman Registration we see the
prodigy is on a rooftop drunk and is
really kind of screaming at the crowd
below which consists of Ben Urich and
Sally Floyd among a few members of the
press and a multitude of citizens and
it's really just kind of ranting about
how he believes that the superhuman
Registration is an erosion of individual
freedoms and rights and he's really kind
of trying to prove a point here we see
the Tony Sarg and shield arrive and
after a quick skirmish Tony Stark is
successful in defeating prodigy and
takes them away and this I think is very
pivotal when it comes to the civil war
storyline because what we see here is
really kind
a marvel comic's allegory to real world
events that are taking place here in the
United States where people are
sacrificing their own individual freedom
for a measure of personal security and
we see the Sally Floyd is really kind of
providing this monologue as far as the
events go regarding the fight between
prodigy and Tony Stark and Prodigy's
ranting and raving and so on then one of
the most important statements that is
made is that the event as far as this
whole superhuman registration was now
beyond the control of normal humans
there was really nothing they could do
to stop it and even if they could no one
is questioning those in power and the
problem is that nobody ever questions
those in power until it's too late to
question them from there we jumped a
speedball and speedball is in a really
really bad situation we really kind of
pick up with him after he was arrested
and I really kind of came to at the end
of civil war frontline issue number one
and we see that he's held at some
undisclosed location and he's presented
with an ultimatum either he can he can
state that he was at fault he can sign a
form saying that he had screwed up and
that they were the cause the New
Warriors were the cause for nitro
destroying a large portion of Stanford
in addition to joining the shield anti
superhuman Registration movement and
tracking down and arresting superheroes
who refused to register we see that if
he does not sign this that he will be
taken and he will be imprisoned
indefinitely with no kind of trial or
anything like that and again this
touches on the events that we've seen
taking place in the United States where
we saw individuals being interred
without any real kind of trial and being
interred indefinitely for various
actions in addition we see that Robby
Baldwin refuses to sign the form and he
has taken to a prison where he is
released into general population from
there he's ridiculed and abused by
various prisoners who view him as a baby
killer from there we jumped to Norman
Osborn and Norman Osborn has really kind
of revealed to be a person watching
spider-man revealed himself publicly
although we don't really know
immediately that it is Norman Osborn we
see Norman Osborn really kind of fly
into a fit of rage claiming that Peter
Parker broke the rules and then we see
that he is surrounded by two seals
shield agents and they
ask him if he's willing to play by a new
set of rules which brings an end to
civil war frontline issue number two